ich bin ein apple store damit sie etwas
lernen er hat ja selber auch im hohen
alter noch etwas dazulernen und deshalb
kommt jetzt wieder eine junge damit zu
uns von der nicht immer viel und auch
sehr gerne lernen unsere grünland
freitags kommen die fachfrau für
bairische sprache um bayerische kultur
claudia pichler
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wirklich jeder stop
loss unterhalb monsheim
stationären übers heiraten ja aber aber
dezember jetzt doch nicht direkt
heiratsmonat oder mannheim andreas
sommermeyer junior ross oder dies hat
sich geändert als inzwischen kehrte
dezember zu den beliebtesten
heiratsmonat in bayern also das geld
wirklich der trend geht immer mehr zur
last minute hochzeit einmal der vorteil
liegt auf der hand weil du heiratest im
dezember kriegst aber die steuern vom
ganzen jahr zurück also der coach aber
nah zusammen so hätten höhere praktisch
im mai heiraten er wäre der romantik und
im dezember um geld ja und wie
entscheiden sie inzwischen eher fürs
geld wobei sie jetzt friere hat mir
immer gesagt liebe vergeht hektar
besteht das ist stimmt das ist auch
wieder bayerische spruch arbeitslose
dafür entscheidet dass man im dezember
heirat und beim popcorn dann passiert
sowas an ran an den speck wie kriegt man
zu später oder frau ja diese bestimmt
das problem früher hat es für so
notfälle eben anschluss ergeben denn
holz in jedem dorf geben das war quasi
so der heiratsvermittler und wenn jetzt
die sauber und sich spontan bräutigam
gesuchten der schmuse zog passau
ferien rezepte
hat nicht deswegen weil er so wahnsinnig
gut ausgeschaut
aber immer der zügen damals war einfach
die auswahl ihrer agonie zu groß also
schaute zum glück freebase heitzer doch
fischt man sie aus einem partner er aus
dem internet heraus also mit parship
oder elitepartner oder kinder das ist
angefasst so art digitaler otto katalog
oder
diakone sagen also wenn martin darauf
macht dann hast du wirklich wir sind
katalog fotos von eben
paarungswilligen partnern und da
entscheidest du dann ins restaurant raus
und das machst du mit vision war also
wenn da einer nicht gefeit dann wirst du
halt nach links immer und wenn du einer
kreuth dann wischt nach rechts aber
obacht geben
und landete damit durch ihren ruhm zu
ziehen
es ist wie wir dabei so diesen portalen
schaut oder sogar rechts links welche
schritte man bisher nicht aber
immer sagen also friere beim schmusen
horst fischer aufpassen weil die haben
einmal probiert dass das so restposten
unsere jugend also zb so die titel
satire talente wirklich sehr modern
nichts mehr zeit den qualm er habe nicht
eigentlich aber als frau hasst die da
ganz elegant während ihnen nämlich mit
einem schneider helfen
würde jetzt allerdings vielleicht
erzählt schneider hüpfer ist werden die
zuschauer wissen was das ist natürlich
das beschreiben schneider ist eigentlich
derart vorstands der vier zähler und das
kann unter umständen besser scherzte
aber jetzt zum beispiel wenn du so ein
titel los wie ein witz dann horst seid
einfach gesagt vier titel darauf
entweder auf terror seymour kreuth korn
titel double und akon
aufgewandten chance
das herz erwärmen
schön dass du da warst claudia hommer
oder russland
[Applaus]
[Musik]